Nói ngon hai không hai bên lập đối phía lòng 1 năm trá là chung sế rồi
Hồi khả nhiều là thay cơ hộ hộ
Hồi rất nhiều trải nghiệp lắng như vỡ năm bọn nhiều trách thúc
Thật thúc về phía thích chích và thích dễ anh hưởng của thế qua trường với nhiều khai lổ
1 năm bình thường mà không ở trên tay thì nó sẽ dễ lạng rồi
thì mà đối với năm nay để mình lửa lụng lệ đến 1 trong năm với trong tính lực của mình nữa
2 khoai làm những nào 1 năm triển rất nhiều những cái biến chuyển không phải
1 chỉ dây 1 cán dân nào cả mà cũng là 1 cán 1 đất nước
Nhưng mà đối với nó thế này những cái bước qua
Để nó năng 2 khoai thấu mình thì có 1 cái cái bước qua
Nhưng thì bây hòng nó qua thì là càng dây cho em được
Vy thủ cũng tạm hơn trên nó
Hôm nường, phía trước có em thôi này
Nó là nó mấy không hay thấu của mình rồi
Nó sẽ không còn gặp
Nó vẫn nhiều biến động như là năm 2 không phải làm người luôn
Mong mọi người nghe, có thể được có tấm nó
Mong cũng bị ổ định hơn, thỏa đầy năm này
Mình thật tử mong cũng là những hồi thấu quan tẻ
Các đổi thêm và nhiều tức phải em
Châu tất cả mọi người 1 tâm mình nó 2 khoai thấu
Thật nhiều nhiều muốn trước khi mà cũng tử như đi
Nó mới để em cũng chúc kia mọi người phải nghĩ sử như
Chỉu sử như mà...
Hôm bớt thành công được rồi, phải tạm sử như vậy
Chúc xong mọi người là luôn rồi tạo su khỏe
và như thế gián sẽ trinh người bị kiểu thuân để có 1 năm mối.
Trọn vệ, phát thích vừa, thì tiếp chết tất cả mọi người được các mục năm mối,
giữ xuất phỏe, hợp là mình em, và lấy như hành công nhé phục xong.